jason so good to see you buddy how are
you i'm great thank you
very well uh good good you know this is
such a wicked revenge action-packed film
i mean what does it mean for you to to
work with mr richie again this is your
fourth time together
you guys are like the best of friends
what is it about him that you
want to work with him you know i just
like what he does
there's certain filmmakers that catch
your eye
and above and beyond that uh you know he
gave me a career
i used to work on street corners selling
perfume and jewelry so
i'm forever indebted to the man but i
think creatively
he just hits the nail where i want to
hit you know i like his
i like the way i like this you know the
premise of
certain movies that he makes and you
know he called me up he said you want to
make this dark film it's uh base
it took him about 30 seconds uh and i
said of course i'm in
uh simple as that it was and the core of
this film is about a dad and his son did
that intrigue that storyline in any way
yeah uh i think everyone could i mean
most
myself i could certainly dive a little
deeper into the emotion of what that
that yeah you could imagine actually
it's unimaginable to
what it would be to lose a son um so
yeah i think having a son is
uh certainly allows me to sort of um
dig deeper into that sort of on the the
unimaginable of what that is
yes and dude you shot post malone
yeah yeah he asked for it
he uh you couldn't wait he said i'm so
happy to get shot by
uh you know by you jason uh i don't know
what that meant
but uh i earned a lot of respect for
post he was
such a such a charismatic sort of cool
dude
um and it was a shame i had to put a
bullet in him
[Laughter]
you know guy said he didn't know who
post was until he showed up and he was
such a nice guy and he gave him some
lines which i found really intriguing
i think everyone's well aware of who he
is he's a fabulous artist
and uh yeah you know you just wanted to
i think he just called up guy and said
listen i love your movies if you're uh
yeah if you're making one that you can
squeeze me in it was
literally one of those kind of calls
according to guy
now the last time i saw you was in
england i don't think we'll be traveling
for a while and that was for fast and
furious with helen mirren and
so i got to ask you i mean this is the
question you're going to be getting fast
10 would you want it to happen
absolutely you know uh i love
all of what that franchise has done for
me and i appreciate
the uh the opportunity to work with all
those people you know there's some great
make some great friends there you know
justin lin is
uh going to direct that movie so you
know i wanted to work with justin
ever since we sort of met back on far
six he shot
the little tag that i did so um yeah i'd
love to
join the crew the merry men and jason
have you seen the uk um poll that went
out where prince william won
and you came in third and um the rock
came in ninth
oh well the happiest bald man who i mean
what was this
ball man alive
you know for you as an actor and
everything that's happening i hope
you're coping well but what does it mean
for you
to create a film like this and bring
entertainment to your fans
uh you know what the cinemas have been
closed uh they're open
you know it's it's great to see people
going and uh
you know one of the great pleasures that
uh
most people can take from their social
times
is to go see a movie together i mean the
the cinema
is a great place for you to
you know see great stories and have
great you know
great insight to subjects you don't know
about and you get to peer through the
curtain about
you know the criminal stuff that happens
you know it's it's
uh it's a great place it's a a a place
like no other you can't really capture
what the cinema does
on your sofa it just no it's not the
same thing agree
agree and you go back into do did you do
your stunts
in the still uh we always get i mean i'm
i get paid a lot of money these days
so they like to get their money's worth
it's no good me sitting on a chair
and yeah you know having somebody else
do all my
hard work so yeah but i know what i do i
mean
you know he's you know since we made
those movies years ago
my my journey's been quite different you
know i mean i sort of went into the
action
uh world quite deeply and i've done many
many
sort of choreographed stylistic fights
and
he just didn't want to embrace any of
that stuff he wanted something very
pretty
and very organic and we we had a
completely different approach
uh you know hence the you know the the
authentic sort of violence that is in
this movie it's uh it's
it's there for the right reason though
it is brilliant and you and i work
together
working together is brilliant if you
were to work on another project that
wasn't about
action-packed like this what kind of
genre would you want to do with guy
uh well we've already done another movie
we've done a spy movie uh an action film
that's slightly you know lighter in its
tone
we uh we just finished we we went to
turkey and we uh
we wrapped you know literally a month
ago
congratulations man we've started
something
thank you so much jason it's good seeing
and hopefully i'll see you in england
next time i see you and do these
interviews somewhere else
in the world